[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANS DANNEELS: We have
developed a platform
to build wearable health
solutions that can track people
at home and do things that
they usually do in hospitals,
or they're not done at all.
So what you have
today is, on one hand,
you have consumer devices that
are very comfortable but not
very accurate.
On the other hand, we
have medical devices that
are not comfortable at all.
And so what we do at
Byteflies, we combine both.
HANS DE CLERCQ: Our vision
is to enable wearable health.
We want to make sure that
everybody can use our platform,
and our dream is that
every medical wearable
will be developed on
the Byteflies platform.
To make that possible,
we collaborate
with Android Things,
because Android already
built a whole community
for app development,
and they made possible
that everybody
that wants to build an app
and bring it to the community
can do so.
HANS DANNEELS: From
the start, when
we started building
a Byteflies platform,
we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel.
So for us, we want
to focus really
on the things where we
can make a difference
and tap into existing solutions,
existing technologies,
existing platforms that do
it much better than we do.
And that's a very important
part of using Android Things is
that we can tap into
the infrastructure
but also the stack
that is already set up.
We're talking about securities,
talking about privacy,
talking about
over-the-air updates
that we don't have
to do ourselves
as well, because
that's something
where Google and Android
and Android Things
is very strong at.
And then we can focus on
accurate data collection,
the seamless collection
to the cloud,
and signal processing,
which are our strong points.
Then we don't have
to worry too much
about the other parts,
while still knowing that we
get a very good quality there.
We integrated Android Things
in our docking stations, which
you can consider as a
small computer that sits
at the bedside of the patient.
So they basically wear the
sensor for the full day
or for longer periods,
and at a given moment,
they plug it into
a docking station.
And because of Android Things,
it connects to the cloud
easily.
HANS DE CLERCQ: Every button
that a patient needs to press
is one too many.
We do automatic updates.
Patient doesn't even know it.
We can deploy as many
units as we want.
We have the whole Google Cloud.
We have the whole TensorFlow
technology that is all
embedded in Android Things.
So it's a very strong
framework where we can just
piggyback the tools that we want
and build our own technology
on top of that.
Sometimes you want to develop
everything from scratch,
and that's actually the
worst thing you can do.
HANS DANNEELS: We designed
our platform in a way
that we handle
the data with care
and that it's HIPAA compliant.
But because of Android
Things, we better
control to make sure that
security and privacy is
controlled from the moment
it leaves the device
and it leaves the patient
until it gets to the cloud,
and until it's being
processed there.
We have the vision that
in five to 10 years,
there's going to be an
abundance of health wearables
that are going to
change health care,
and are going to change the
health of everyone around.
We want that these health
wearables are built
on the Byteflies platform.
That's going to
allow to transform
health care from
being 99% curing today
to hopefully 99% prevention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]